uh with a single boom roasted line so uh
any ideas maybe you want to mention
malice but any ideas come to uh mine
when you look at me
man i do you know what uh if i was going
to boom roast someone i would want to
kind of like research their career and
dissect them and figure out their
biggest get to the core and i did i
didn't have that notion with you i
figured i
got a general sense of okay he's really
successful he's super sharp uh he's
really interested in some really
interesting things i bet we'll have a
great conversation but i had no
intention to roast you yeah there you go
what about mouse you had dinner with him
last night hmm for him
oh man
um how'd you get to know him by the way
just twitter there's the most magical
place in the world right i always tell
you it's a great source of information
if you know how to use it um
hmm
he's insane on twitter actually he's so
i had to unfollow him on twitter because
he it was too intense it's just too much
no it's too much it fills up like i want
to be able to consume the content so if
i want to see something he says i can go
to his page right
but it's just too much for my timeline i
want to be able to consume who i follow
so i try to not follow a lot of people
because i want to be able to consume
them um and he was he was too much he
yeah he fights the trolls which uh
i don't know why we would ever fight the
trolls there's just too many of them
well he's the troll himself he's like
the big troll fighting the little trolls
he's the king troll there's a million of
them so even if you kill if you kill a
hundred thousand they're still not a
hundred thousand left does just keep
calling he's gonna ignore him
like the night walker or whatever yeah
well i'll take it because you had
nothing um you could you couldn't roast
gsp out of respect too yeah so i'm just
going to take that as a sign what do you
say bad about gsp
now i try to roast his hair like why are
you trying to grow grow hair now after
all these years he looked good bald
everyone loved him with his head shaved
yeah now it looks kind of strange like
why you got hair now well it was one of
the more surreal moments of my life is
so he was here and he wore a black suit
and tie
oh really yeah we did the podcast with
him just mirror image of me
and then we also did uh i haven't
released it yet but just a video
together and i was doing a martial arts
stuff in in a suit and tie
that was quite that was quite uh
that that's like
like certain moments in your life are
just like
i can't believe i was part of that yeah
from uh with gsp uh so yeah i don't i
don't think i have anything to roast him
about um
i mean maybe the matt sarah thing would
be the one that you could get him with
you know but uh yeah i would be i would
be really fascinated like really dig
deep uh from a sports psychology
standpoint because he always talks about
how much fear he had when he was
competing and i find that to be
interesting because obviously so it's
almost like to me it's almost like
was he successful
despite that not because of that right
and because anxiety usually leads to
really negative performance for the
majority of people and what was it about
him that the anxiety wasn't super
negative you know what i'm saying like
it's it's very interesting i wonder that
too so i have
i wanted that about him but i have a
huge amount of anxiety interacting
especially with people just about
everything yeah i wonder if that's
helpful or or not it feels like it's
very helpful well i think so it's okay i
think in two different things so i think
uh probably your everyday life okay is
different than like in a performance or
a a competition it's you have to be like
super in the moment of what you're doing
so anything that's pulling you away like
oh my gosh
high school kids right that coach oh my
gosh my that girl's in the stands and if
i get beat then and they're actually
they're actively thinking about this
other thing when this is going on and i
need a hundred percent of your focus
he's never i don't think he has anxiety
in the ring that's the point i think
like
i have the same thing like if i have a
really high performance thing
that i have to do uh i don't know i'll
let you in front of a lot of people yeah
that'd be a great example
that there's huge amount of anxiety
weeks ahead days ahead hours ahead so
you have a system to get rid of it then
maybe but it's just the body gets rid of
it somehow yeah there's not a system
subconscious system yeah it's so you
don't
actually have anxiety while you're
performing so that's like so then then
that problem somehow that problem has
solved itself right the problem is when
the anxiety is actually happening while
the wrestling match is happening that's
the real issue yeah but it's it like
sneaks in there too is that's the
difference between mma in wrestling is
there's no breaks in wrestling right
yeah i guess there is you can look at
the crowd a little bit like you can look
so maybe maybe but like the there's
other things we have to perform
well there's more breaks like a lecture
you can catch yourself thinking like in
this conversation you know yeah like
i'll i've said a bunch of stuff where i
think
why the hell did you say that that's
dumb right that that's the anxiety
because there's a pause
and that that that could be um i don't
know i i think it just pushes me to be
better but maybe i could be way better
if i let go of that yeah it's scary to
think that jsp if you let go that way
because he didn't even
like you're saying like
you don't necessarily feel those so i
think certain people that i've coached
like they would describe how they would
feel literally during the wrestling
match right and you're saying like
during the
speech performance it's mostly gone yep
and that's that's it would be
interesting to see if like
you know he talked a lot about that but
if he was all if he was all the way
somehow gone and he it means he would
have a mechanism for it so i had a
really bad performance my freshman year
of high school at nationals
because i had i had the ability to be
anxious and one of my coaches talked
about like and a lot of a type
personalities are kind of that way you
know because they're trying to consider
all possibilities at the same time and
and while we're actually performing or
competing it's negative to performance
right um so he said he would always
leading up to the match within say an
hour he would his name was talking about
fishing he would get someone to talk
about fishing with him because they
would stop him thinking about the match
and and being uber anxious so i always
kind of really took that heart and it
really helped me as i would always like
have someone to talk to and just just
goof around about whatever so i'm not
thinking about this thing and then once
i step in it's time to go so i didn't
have this like anxious buildup and that
was how for me i took it away but like
me you know like you said you have
a way to get it away obviously because
yeah i guess so i guess there's little
little tricks you come up with yeah you
start thinking about not fishing maybe i
should try the fishing thing but i hate
fishing so bored
well maybe maybe it's good to think
about that
all right ben this is uh like i told you
i'm a big fan i'm a big fan of your
wrestling your fighting your personality
uh thank you for coming down thank you
for talking today appreciate it huge
honor
bam let's go wrestle
you